yeah yeah my ugly daddy thinks you're
beautiful but let me tell you nobody
ever wanted to touch you growing up so
right here oh my god have you ever had a
moment growing up where you're like am i
gay you know I think that moment only
happened because people were [ __ ]
around I'm glad that you actually have
had one because I've had one for sure if
I want to hear yours I feel I don't know
if it's because I thought I was gay I
think it's because as a kid you're gay
and that word it didn't really have that
definitive meaning of like um because I
feel like when we use that where you're
gay it was just as an insult had nothing
to do with sexuality right yeah but I
think when people started joking around
with it a lot though you could probably
be gay yeah yeah okay can that happen
like can I be gay yeah does that work
that way right and I think I feel like a
lot of boys felt that [ __ ] Oh first sure
well I have this theory that every guy
has had a mi hey my game Oh every guy
for sure especially gays that mean
that's where they were like oh yeah for
sure gay moment will you chill at your
homey and just you guys are having such
a good [ __ ] time yeah over items like
amen
well can't my girl just be like you it's
like yeah girl be you guys weird right
right yeah bro I'd like I've had those
I've had those moments bro or it's like
cuz cuz also like in school I wasn't um
I wasn't a jock I wasn't super athletic
I boxed you know but I was really into
dancing I was into arts and crafts I was
into crocheting like my dad walked in
walked in on me crocheting and my dad
was like you might be gated yeah your
dad came in as like boy I thought you
boxing if my dad were like making me a
[ __ ] beanie why aren't you why I
thought you'll be walking in on you like
jacking off yes and but your crocheting
you know start jacking off immediately
I'm a closest damn door and I want to
hear some thumpin
yeah bro and so that was my thing I was
like I'm not I don't feel as masculine
so I was like damn
am i gay you know I've had those moments
for sure yeah I think that's more of a
lot of kids or guys feel like they might
be homosexual not because of their
actual sexual attraction towards another
male is because a lot of people put
masculinity on things that aren't really
masculine or feminine right yeah for
example crocheting like making [ __ ]
why is that considered quote unquote
gift yeah right he's making [ __ ] right
even for me I didn't join quiet for the
longest time because I was scared bro
yes in elementary school I think choir
was only for girls yeah that was it and
my brother was like my brother's like
dude don't don't quad cuz I wanted to do
choir cause I want to learn how to sing
yeah I never did because I thought it
was something girls did girls that's
what I'm saying so there's just a lot of
and you know things are changing a lot
now yeah but for sure there was just a
lot of things that were put as only guys
do this only girls through this yeah for
example this is a great example I didn't
use a lotion because I thought that [ __ ]
was for [ __ ] I was like you use
lotion you [ __ ] [ __ ] but you can't
throw a fist where the [ __ ] does dry
skin got a ding a man or yeah so a lot
of dudes they don't do skincare [ __ ]
they don't use lotion on their face and
all the other stuff and I didn't use it
for the longest time until Mary oh my
fiance told me my fin my skin was
trashed
I said what you talkin bout my skin is
fine jeez I know it's dry as hell
o-tama and then as I'm speaking like
flakes are coming off my face but I
didn't know this type of stuff about
skin care and my skin was terrible
because something in the back of my mind
told me that skin cares for a bunch of
pansies and wusses yeah so you don't do
that type of [ __ ] really you're just
moisturizing your [ __ ] skin right
doesn't make any sense but all that
stuff as a kid affects you as an adult
right so all that you know pro man [ __ ]
that I thought that only guy should do
or only girl should do those type of
activities is never touched right and
eventually like what the whole choir
thing I was like yeah I'm gonna [ __ ]
join choir and I'm good and I'm gonna
sing and I'm gonna do it publicly and
I'm gonna see what's gonna happen like
right who the [ __ ] cares yeah and which
doesn't make any sense because my
Persinger's we're we're [ __ ] male
singers yeah that's what I will say I
was like you got Michael Jackson uh sure
Chris Brown Justin Bieber and they all
got mad [ __ ] so I'm like what you
mean this is Gaelic I could have been
that yeah that was my first concert I
ever went to was ushered 8701 is my
first color and I knew at that moment I
want to be an entertainer that's why
that's where I found out I want to be
entertainer because there was one guy on
the stage we're in a whole stadium yeah
and people just roaring roaring for this
one guy and I was like that's just so
badass he was dancing it was so [ __ ]
cool so I was like yeah that's what I
want to do but singing I was like I
can't think so maybe I just made a man
who knows if they didn't crush your
dreams you could have been the next
Usher
bro that way you dance they don't tell
me though yes yeah real talk that's why
I can't sing these [ __ ] go no yeah I
was I was dancing all through high
school but not seen but that's what I
was but I was performing in talent shows
dancing I was and that's what I was
known for before even comedy I was known
for dancing yeah yeah so but that was
like that was my thing I was like
alright imma imma take singing lessons
later like in life but I'm gonna get
them dancing down right I got into
acting so I okay I got the acting down I
wanted to be a triple threat so bad you
know I wanted to just be like a gym like
a box yeah yeah yeah Jamie Foxx dancing
was the [ __ ] though I think honestly out
of all the talents in terms of getting
women to be attracted to you the dancers
always had the best they will always get
the most one the only thing with me with
dancers but this is what kind of threw
me off because I was like everybody was
like oh damn that's gonna be cool like
you'll be like Chris Brown's backup
dancers you'll be Usher's backup dancers
and I saw that as like I'm gonna be a
background dancer yeah I feel like I was
like nobody pays attention to the
background now I know now like there's a
lot of famous dancers that you want to
see that are with Beyonce like the last
ones like there yeah you're watching the
them because you're fans of them and of
course they're on with Beyonce but I was
always like you're just watching the
main entertainer you're not watching
your dancers yeah so that that also kind
of discouraged me away from wanting to
be a dancer because I was like you're
not gonna be the main show yeah
now that mean of course that's you know
me being ignorant
no there's a ton of successful dancer
that are but you know dancing wasn't as
lucrative as it is now mm-hmm so the
dancing was such a big passion it was a
huge performance art I mind you even a
lot of these great backup dancers just
from what I've heard until they until
that fuse there's a few small select
amount of people that get paid a lot to
choreograph and dance and everything
else but everybody else relatively they
don't for the amount of work that they
do they don't get paid that well unless
you're like lay twins right like for
then because they have a name they can
negotiate their prices right right you
have a walk use like exactly yeah so
prior to the whole social media thing
and people really putting like dancing
on the map like that it wasn't a huge it
wasn't a lucrative business people would
open up their own studios and stuff
right but that was based on a small
group of people who wanted to learn how
to dance right because prior to the
whole you know what's it called not
America like ABDC imagine it's dance
crew right right how many I mean I knew
about a few boutique hip-hop studios
right or you would join like a small
dance troupe and then you will learn how
to dance there right but there wouldn't
be these hardcore intensive hip-hop
classes where you learn how to dance on
these great choreographers all right it
wasn't really no but now you have stuff
like movement life style what everybody
wants to go there right and they get
some of the best [ __ ] hip-hop
choreographers around around the world
yes trained people in the classes which
is amazing yeah bro cuz because you
probably had to learn how did you learn
how to dance on you know yeah that's how
most people did it you got served
yeah they had special features or where
they did little at the end with the
other DVD you can they had like you
could learn a couple like choreographies
yeah that they had the the main
choreographer that that taught that's
still around all of them dance yeah I
watched that like over and over and then
we don't two came out I was watching all
the Omarion videos Chris Brown videos
and just well that [ __ ] movie made
everybody want to dance yeah even me I
knew I couldn't dance my [ __ ]
you best believe I'd be somebody that
itas somebody to do a backflip I'm not
the [ __ ] you gonna jump at me right I
don't dance right imma toss your [ __ ]
ass like a coin and I'm gonna get the
glory because I threw you yeah
that was the thing trying to serve
people yep sir
sir yes sir doing it for a little saint
yeah yeah he was [ __ ] dope yeah I
don't think it's one of those it's
probably one of the best dance movies
out there man in terms of like hip hop
acting's trash oh who the [ __ ] cares
about that though I had no idea that the
acting was tried until like I watched it
now I had no idea that it was like what
is this